PMP HAS SNT
NG T DARETWEETING SOMETHI
LIKEOR8:CALMING THEHATRUIETO U.
AATJOURNAS,HE ALSEETING HT THISG
NGO A
DEFENSE S IF ITNTE O FROMY
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.GN THE ERO
UNAIE MORE ONTHIS. Y THIS INPR ?
HAS ENP? IN THEVIEW, HE'SRYN FR
AS HE'SK T
TH ESHEDULE.
WHATUTTHIS,KATE, FROM HIS OWNHE
STILL
YEER BNT
WHERE THEYNK I
GOING,CH DR. SAID IS
THE DIRECTION AND THENNC PTHIS.
WHERE HE'S NOT PRETENDING TO PU.
OICE PRCE HASNHE
CONA  WHITE HOUSE OFTEN TS FOR
WITHHESEESRGG,
SURGING AND R
ACROSS THE COTRTES
OR PAUSE SOMETHING
NOT THE WANTED TO
SEE ANDHEPRESIDENT GOINGTO V TH
HE ITODA THE
TSSOMING FROM HEALTHFIE TO
DOING SO.
ON OD TWEET
ABOUT THIS MORNGTE
NG H A OMPTER WHEN TAK S OMT,
KATE, WTOTABLY TO, THE CBIDEN'S
MOCKNTAYINGHE WAS IS, VD HSE A
RESIDENTEC
ND A SAYING HERED T SAYINGTHAT A
WITH HISEADERSHIP
PAIC WASHING HANNG IT BD HIM.
THATING CRIMING FRO SPRESIDENT I
IA AS HETWULTIPLEWERLYOU8:00.KA,
TH IT ALL
TOGETH.
APPRECIATE
DEBATING AND T'S A LOTOHEEDSSIA
RY AS ME P.
HEALLING IT A SIN SAID
HE WASN'TIEFED. W HE DID
GETIEFED.NOEOEIE LL IWAS A HOAXE
R  WTHIS.
MY SON WAS A MARINE INGHANIS IE
AC HELLOIKETHSCORD.HEIESAC T
REALITY.
NCORETSTONE SCHMIDT JUST 24D KI
FRIENDLY FIRE
ER BECKY WH
SHENOW.
THANK U,MUCH,
HERE,IR AK YOU FOR YOURERR THE F
I READ Y AND  I --AND WAS
CONCLUSION EEA
BUT ALS OF
SOMETHING TUST NOT BEOST
IN ISEN
SER Y OVERSEWAWHAT WAS YOUR RE
RO THAT INTELLIGENCE WASISEWNOE
FIESUS BECAUSEE -ILD ONES NEED
EYOF. THE
HASO I HEA,
THINKING TIONHAPPENED.
WE TKN Y
GOTO AUTAGAIN?
THATLLHO LOSTOV,
SU B SOMESTAKE OR  WE NEED THE
THAT SITUATION WASD AND GOING TG
DIDN'T  SUS,
US THINK THATOUKNOW, HE'SPING OY
HE ABOUTTHS US
ON RIDE ONT YET TR HISO KEEP US
OMS CANPIN BIT.
WE NEED SEE .>>S IT -- I IS, IT
STNG,S
THE PAST COUPL
THE PRESIDE NOT
MILITARY FAMILIES SINCE THI ALL
NOTHING WHICH I'VE HER
TO DOHI  TEVE EOVNO BOTHERTHE
WE NEEDOMNEASSUREHE TOP
OF INTELLIGENCE DER TO KEEP OUTA
SO SOMETHIIKE A
IS H DENYI EN AS
ANYTHIUT HAVEYOU  WN , WHAT  I
MEAN, YOU'REOI FEELH YOUR LIFE
BETTER IF W
SITUATIOPENEDHA KS GOING T N TH
FOUD ANTY O
HA AH.YOU KNT W YOUANY G STAR PS
DO FEEL  BEEN A LOTFOR US IN T
U  OHAT  KHE FOR
IEM GEORGE SHOM STAROL SLITARY
HERE'S HEINGSTES AND JUSTEE REM
SO, OW O THING AT WILLE I TOTEVD
REIT.
E WON OUR ONES M TBO THERE WAS
I NEED TO THAT NO OTHER
FAMILYS GOING SUFE
EOPRESOLVED, ANDT OUT  BUT IN
THERS JUSTICE.
U IT' -
FEELING I
THO JT
S WHAT GOLDS FEEL T
O THER
DEATHERET HAVE DIDN'T HAVE DTEM
THAT KEPT THEM AS SAFE AS THEY
N  YEAH.D BEAUTIFUL SON
SCHMISEN HIS
SERVE NOTVAOUR S
R TODA